for now though we're going to move on to
here in germany well the country is
still reeling from last week's flooding
and the cabinet has now approved a 400
million euro relief package for the
victims
chancellor angela michael has pledged to
do everything possible to ensure that
the funds are delivered quickly to those
in need
more than 160 people are known to have
died in the disaster
with dozens more still unaccounted for
hard-hit communities are now confronting
the daunting rebuilding process
until a few days ago this was a sterile
environment
a clean place where cancer and dialysis
patients received medical care
but then the flood waters came to the
san antonio's hospital in eschmeler
equipment was destroyed 300 patients
were evacuated
professor uber janssence is a senior
consultant here
and one of germany's leading experts on
the corona pandemic
but right now he has just one focus
for us it's important to show that the
hospital will not cease to exist i'm
absolutely sure we will achieve that
people need us and we will rebuild
volunteers and staff are pitching in for
now
but janssen's is conscious that
reconstruction will take
time and ultimately public cash will be
needed
the state and the federal government are
meeting in berlin
and they will release recovery funds but
we've already heard this is going to
swallow up billions
the politicians are proposing a package
of immediate assistance to the region
worth 400 million euros
and their promising help will come
quickly and without bureaucracy
the financial aid must go speedily to
the people many of whom have nothing
more than the clothes on their backs and
are completely reliant on this health
the forms and the application procedures
have to be as simple as possible
and they must be ready in the course of
the week so that the first
payments can go ahead as soon as
possible
the floods could leave a deep hole in
public finances
across parts of western germany roads
bridges rail lines will all need
repairing and replacing
the 2002 flood on the elba and the
danube rivers ran up a bill of around 13
billion euros in germany
the rebuilding this time may well cost
much more
amid criticisms about the failure of
warning systems
and the speed of the emergency response
one thing the political leaders can do
is direct money to where it is so
urgently needed
all right let's check in with an our
reporter now benjamin alvarez-gruber
he's on the ground
covering the latest developments in the
town of badminster ifa
benjamin there are now also fears of
coronavirus spreading faster
how are health authorities responding to
that threat
that's right sumi we are not in
badminton alpha we were there yesterday
today we are in avila one of the worst
hit
is cities in the state of
rhineland-palatinate where local
authorities and state authorities fear
that the areas affected by the floods
might also
become a super spreader event so they
brought
a mobile vaccination center it's a bus
that you can see here right behind me
where not only residents but also
volunteers can come here
to get their job without an appointment
yesterday there was the first day of
this bus more than 260 people
got the jab here and there will be also
teams going to the emergency shelters
where local authorities fear
that their risk of getting infected with
corvette 19 is especially high
dozens and dozens of people in the area
are still unaccounted for so what can
you tell us at this point about rescue
efforts where you are
rescue efforts continue around the clock
there are several groups involved
there is on one side police there are
also soldiers that have been deployed to
the area
and the civil emergency organization is
also hearing a lot of volunteers
we spoke to firefighters and they told
us that they are still trying to pump
water out of houses
and of underground parking lots where
many well some people are still feared
to be
inside of those cars so the search
continues
there are a lot of people involved also
to give advice and guidance
and also psychological support to the
families of people that are still
searching for their relatives here in
the area you mentioned psychological
support i mean at this point benjamin
what are the biggest challenges
to provide relief to the victims
the biggest challenges are logistical
ones that are still places where it's
real
really difficult to get there when we
look at the riverbanks
very small towns where still
firefighters are still trying
to make it to those places many bridges
have been destroyed many streets
have been destroyed we've seen city
centers also where
the water washed away entire cars so
they're
working block block after block house
after house trying to pump
water out there sludge out there and
there also a lot of
volunteers supporting there so what
we've seen over the past days is a lot
of solidarity a lot of volunteers who've
made it
to the place and now supporting the
rescue groups to get much needed help
but also to get food also to get
donations
and try to get to the people as fast as
possible
dws benjamin alvarez guber reporting for
us there on the ground
thank you very much
now to provide more assistance to the
victims just a short while ago the
german government approved an emergency
aid package
for the flood-hit regions and our chief
political
correspondent melinda crane joins us
from outside the chancellery for more
on this story hi melinda the interior
minister just
outlined how this relief package should
be made available very quickly to the
victims so tell us more about what was
said
indeed the interior minister and the
finance minister have been holding a
press conference after the cabinet
returned from its summer
break to meet here at the chancellery
and
both ministers said that there was
complete agreement among the cabinet
members
that this aide needed to get out fast
and without
the normal bureaucratic hurdles so that
can be something of a stretch for
germany
but the fact is that it does have some
practice now
after uh having provided pandemic
relief in many cases also with very
quick
unbureaucratic processes what does
unbureaucratic mean well it means
there's no detailed means testing people
won't have to fill out
a lot of forms or go through a lot of
hurdles what the two ministers also
had to say is that this initial pot of
400 million in total that's 200 million
federal funding and 200 million in
matching funds from the 16 federal
states
that this will be augmented as needed
with the finance minister
minister saying if we need to do more we
absolutely
will do more and they said that longer
term we're looking at expenditures
for uh repairing and rebuilding more
resilient
infrastructure resilient infrastructure
meaning infrastructure
that can truly withstand withstand
further storms of this kind of magnitude
that this will cost at least 6 billion
euros
based on the experiences with past
floods but as we know
even the worst of the past floods were
scarcely comparable to this disaster
the worst in 60 years so we're likely
looking at far
larger expenditures than that for the
medium to longer term
our chief political correspondent linda
crane from the chancellery there thank
you